se placer sur l'écran radar sans trop
faire de vagues la dernière chose que
souhaite des vies et de se mettre à dos
le gouvernement fédéral elle choisit
bien ses mots et on a travaillé deux
mois là dessus on veut faire le travail
voici ce que donnerait le projet final
de davy un porte-conteneurs commercial
transformé en navire ravitailleur qui
seraient loués à la défense nationale il
permettrait d'alimenter en carburant en
vivres et munitions les frégates et
destroyers en mission à l'étranger la
marine en a un urgent besoin elle n'a
plus de ravitailleurs c'est très bon
pour la marine c'est très bon pour le
pays
c'est très bon pour nos employés nos
trick
or des sources confirment à radio canada
que le cabinet devaient être saisis du
dossier mardi mais qu'il a été retiré de
l'ordre du jour à la dernière minute
nous attendons les évaluations de la
défense explique la ministre pourtant
nos sources confirment que la marine a
clairement indiqué au gouvernement que
la divine est l'option qu'elle
privilégie mettant y aura-t-il une
décision c'est ce que les gens veulent
savoir parce que le temps presse vous
savez très bien de temps godbout comme
vous le savez le projet lettre est allé
dessus et je vais faire mon travail de
député de lévis bellechasse avec fierté
merci des vies se trouve justement dans
le comté du ministre si vous devez ni
dans une région courtisé par les
conservateurs rolen secret les 400
familles car il mènerait les têtes qui
comprend pas mais voilà quelqu'un
comprennent la bon sens les pressions
viennent de partout enfin cette fois que
j'appelle le gouvernement fédéral j'ai
parlé à six semaines et j'écris à une
ministre les conservateurs se garde s'il
une carte dans leur jeu attenti la
campagne électorale pour faire une
annonce les experts sont presque tous
unanimes plus le gouvernement attend
plus ça se fait au détriment de la
marine et de l'industrie pas de décision
avant juin causerait un retard d'au
moins 90
minutes mais ce dossier s'ajoute aux
nombreux ratés des dernières années dans
les acquisitions militaires mais cette
fois dans le contexte d'une campagne
électorale la pression ne fera que
s'accentuer
ici marc godbout radio canada ottawa